hi i'm aidan gallagher and i play number
five on the umbrella academy
i am david castaneda and i play diego hi
my name is justin min
and i play ben hargreaves hello i am
captain robert sheehan you fellow flesh
bag
and i play dr klaus i'm emmy river
lantman
and i play allison hargreaves i am ellen
page and i play
vania hargreaves hello i'm tom hopper
and i play luther hargreaves
on the umbrella academy and we will be
taking the buzzfeed quiz
to find out which umbrella academy
characters we are
how would your bffs describe you clumsy
guarded charming romantic badass loyal
i mean my instinct is badass but i'm
going to have to go with loyal i think
i i think loyal well if they're my bffs
you know what i mean
they're probably they're going to be as
rude and demeaning as they could
possibly be be which is which is what i
would expect for them probably go with
charming let's say charming for rob
i would say loyal for justin well
if they are my best friend forever then
i suppose
i would have to be quite loyal that's a
long time to stay with somebody
i think that might be the definition of
loyalty yeah
i'm definitely not badass my friends
aren't really that emotionally available
so i would say loyal pick the superhero
you relate to the most
superman wonder woman black panther
spider-man storm there's just something
so
cool about tablet bozeman i'm gonna go
with black panther there are two sides
to this really
one which super powers would you like
two which personalities most suit you
i'm not nearly as guarded as batman but
that man is cool
i'd probably say i'm most like
spider-man i'm a high school student
and sometimes i can be quite silly i
don't know enough about the backstory of
wonder woman or storm i think i'm storm
what'd you say ellis
spiderman
he's kind of like you know awkward a bit
and but then he's like
shoo shoo and like not like nuts
strong you know i've gone superman
because i feel like i
kind of have two sides to me like i have
like a goofier side which is kind of
clark kent and then i have like quite a
serious
disciplined side which is more when he's
superman
probably black panther
i'm gonna say storm what are you most
likely doing
in your free time sleeping dancing
shopping
cooking watching tv or texting i'd be
either sleeping or
cooking i love a bit of cooking let's go
with cooking sleeping makes me sound
like a lazy bastard
i would say sleeping so i guess i am the
lazy
lazy pup i would say dancing you are an
awesome dancer you are always
impeccable whenever we have like wrap
parties yeah well that's because of the
tequila baby
well if you're dancing i'll be dancing
with you buddy i'm definitely cooking
these days cooking i'm not doing much of
any of these
was like we need a reading option yeah
reading should be on there
i guess i i mean i might just it's crazy
to be like i guess i catch up on
sleep you know when you have free time
pick an early
2000s song to jam out to
get your freak on by missy elliott thong
song
by cisco a thousand miles by vanessa
carlton
hey yeah by outcast i'm like a bird by
nelly furtado
wherever whenever by shakira i mean it's
definitely the thong song because
baby
yeah i think i'm gonna go thong song i
mean it's a bop
it's about such a bop i think i'm
done by missy elliot for sure can't not
dance like it doesn't matter what's
going on
if it came on right now i'd be like see
you guys later i'd go with hey yeah by
outcast in that list
what are the second lyrics to whenever
wherever whenever we're meant to be
together i'll be there and you'll be
here oh yeah that's that's definitely me
i'm gonna go with nelly furtado
dope song man i'll probably go with hey
yeah which
member of the commission would you want
to be for a day cha-cha
hazel and the handler hamlet there's a
nice sort of humility to hazel and a
nice sort of reserved
sweetness that cameron brings to that
role so i'll go with hazel
like the handler is serving me like
wardrobe
goals and options and like the
cigarettes like cruella de vil with the
cigarette
i think i'd be here for the props i
think i might
eat cha-cha i think the han low just
because she's got like kind of swag
i think the handler because there's less
there's less likelihood you'll have to
splat someone's brains all over the wall
i don't know if i'd be into that i'd
probably choose hazel because
he gets to eat donuts and he has that
nice love story with agnes pick a treat
from gritty's donuts strawberry doughnut
chocolate doughnut white chocolate tone
glazed doughnut i don't trust glaze
cookie crumble donut
jelly filled doughnut i think i'm gonna
go for a jelly filled donut
i'm gonna go with the one that you just
hated on the classic glaze why don't you
trust glazed you know it's because it's
invisible mate
you know the glaze is highly underrated
and probably my favorite i'll go with
the glazed doughnut as well
i used to absolutely nail an entire box
of krispy kreme original
glazed donuts like no problem they were
so good so i'm going to go with the
original glazed
i used to always as a kid at tim hortons
shout out canada the chocolate dip
donut i'm a pink with sprinkles finally
choose an iconic moment in history to
travel back to
the moon landing the invention of
broadcast television
the march on washington the birth of
william shakespeare
the first performance by the beatles in
south england or muhammad ali's boxing
match against
sunny liston in 1965. you would
definitely choose that one i know
no question but who wants to see the
birth of william
shakespeare i was gonna choose that one
are you gonna be there to catch him when
he comes out
exactly and to hold him in my arms it's
like holding any baby
but i would still be able to say i held
william
shakespeare when he was birthed
obviously the march on washington
i'm going to go with the first
performance by the beatles i'm a big
beatles fan for the first performance by
the beat was in south england that would
be pretty epic to go to
and we all know that i'm going with
muhammad ali
i'm going with you buddy
i got number two diego hargreaves
i got you
you got luther hargreaves space point
number one
i got the boy i got the boy
slash number five honestly thrilled
i also got uh the boy number five
i got klaus hargreaves everyone's
favorite slacker
i'm like i'm not a slugger at all i work
real hard
uh have you seen her documentaries oh my
god
you don't like to be tied down guess
what that's okay
you tend to get bored easily and talk to
yourself when nobody's watching
yet somehow you get things done i'm the
one that answered the questions so i'm
gonna have to sit with it
you may have a baby face but you're
often regarded as the wisest
in your friend groups definitely have an
old soul to match your youthful spirit
never doubt your ability to make real
changes in this world
i'm not as much as a little [ __ ] as he
is in the show though you can be a
little
okay very hot-headed at times sad
but it's only because you're passionate
you know and you care deeply about the
people
and the things you love and you like to
stab people in the guts
crikey buzzfeed that's a bit much you're
the protector and you wear
that hat or coat nothing gets past you
and you'll do anything to make sure your
family and friends are safe
more than likely you also gave the best
hugs
which is true
you